all right fig lovers this is Ross the
Fig boss in today's video we're going to
talk about growing fig trees in
containers and I think you guys are in
real special hands today because I have
dedicated a large portion of the last 10
years so learning as much as I can about
this very special fruit tree
the Fig
and I've also spent during this time a
lot of that time growing figs in
containers but also growing other
species of fruiting plants in containers
as well I've grown a number of different
varieties hundreds of different trees
in containers and I have a lot of good
advice I want to share with you guys in
today's video we're going to try to make
this as simple as possible in regards to
these fig trees so the first thing I
think that's really important
can you actually grow fig trees in
containers I know that's pretty simple
the answer is yes and I find that of
most of the fruiting species that you
can grow in containers they do fantastic
the problem with the fig tree
in a container is that you met you got
to make sure that you put it in the
right size if it's too small of a pot
this is a two gallon size here it's
about eight inches by eight inches
you're not going to see great production
you're not going to see great fruit set
you're not going to see good fruit
quality and it's just kind of going to
be a waste of your time I find
if you're going to grow fruit fig trees
guys in containers you got to grow them
in at least a three gallon I mean look
at the difference in the size and the
productivity
between the two trees I just showed you
they're actually similarly aged believe
it or not
and this tree here in front of me is
probably going to produce close to 50
figs every year if you really know what
you're doing
versus the other size that may if I'm
lucky produce 20 or 25.
so that's a big jump from just a two
gallon size pot actually to a to a three
gallon size pot
and I would also recommend by the way
going in a larger size as you can handle
so I have five gallons in here I have 10
gallons in there I also have 15 Gallons
back on the other side of the patio
and those I think are great because they
obviously the trees produce more fruit
in that size
but those are more of my permanent fruit
trees my permanent fig trees in
containers because if I'm going to be
growing figs long term in a container I
want to make sure I have the a bigger
pot size first off they're going to
produce more fruit but also I'm not
going to have to typically root burn
them as often they're not going to
become as root bound
as quickly and in these smaller sizes
here like this three gallon we'll
probably have to root from this maybe
every other year every three years just
to maintain the health and the
productivity of this tree
also if I went from let's say a three
gallon size or a five gallon size which
is going to produce about 75 figs a year
and then I went up to a 10 gallon I'm
gonna probably double my production so I
would go from 75 figs to 150. so the
larger I can go the larger I can carry
the better off I'm going to be the
problem is with a lot of us in zone
sevens sixes and fives we have to move
our fig trees in the wintertime
and really some zones Zone eights some
of you guys in zone eights may have to
move them as well if our fig trees get
below 15 degrees Fahrenheit
in the winter time we need to move them
away from those cold temperatures that
15 degree low maybe even around 10
degrees Fahrenheit is going to damage
the roots of our fig tree and
potentially kill it especially on the
low uh the lower Hardy varieties that
you guys may have everybody has a
different fig variety and so giving you
just that General recommendation of 15
degrees Fahrenheit would be the safe
number for all fig varieties you want to
make sure they are kept out of that cold
and so that's the beauty of growing them
in containers why would you even grow
them in a container
personally you need to be in either a
short season climate that you can
benefit by getting your fig tree awake
earlier getting it a head start and
making use of having a warmer soil
temperature
or you need to be living in a very cold
place where you just can't grow fig
trees in the ground and so that's the
main concern I have with the pot size
is that yes I would like to go as large
as possible to get as much fruit as
possible to also have to root prune
typically less
but
I'm gonna have to move it at some point
so a 55 gallon drum or a half whiskey
barrel might be too big might be too
heavy might be too much to deal with
especially if you have a lot of fig
trees so for me
the three gallon or the five gallon size
actually is perfect and if I have a more
permanent tree I like to go to the 10
but a 15 is almost a little too heavy
even for me to move so that's a big
lesson there
now let's talk about caring for them
because
we can't just have a tree in a pot and
expect it to do well one of the most
important things actually is fertilizer
this here is just a bag of slow release
fertilizer it's called florican
and you can also get this by so many
other names there is osmocote they sell
it at Home Depot there's classic coat
they're basically those little beads
that are different colors
they're very small
and these little beads here as an
example sit on top of the soil or mixed
in the top of the soil and they slowly
provide fertilizer to our fig trees
every time we water
and so this just makes it super easy I
mean you can't get any easier they've
already designed essentially on the bag
you'll read about the nutrients that are
in here obviously you want something
close to a 10 10 10 or as close as you
can get to a 10 10 10 or a 20 10 20 is
also really good
but they also include in the bag all the
different micronutrients that your trees
might need and so you essentially you
can just apply this and be done with it
I mean this is the really the simplified
version of it if you want to get really
technical
I would recommend going to the blog that
I mentioned before figboss.com guys
we have a whole different article
written there that's so much information
about fertilizing if you really wanted
to get in the weeds of it but this is a
one-time application that I do every
single spring to every container fig
tree you read the label on the bag
exactly how much you should apply
and that's it I don't worry about it uh
every time I water for a certain number
of months depending on the fertilizer
you buy
it provides fertilizer and I do it day
one of the growing season as soon as
they start waking up
the next thing in terms of care that's
really critical is water and so
I have all my fig trees believe it or
not hooked up to a automatic Irrigation
Timer
this is drip irrigation down there
see the tubes
and this timer just does it
automatically for me it's rather simple
even if I had a couple fig trees
I would still probably hook them up to
drip irrigation they go through this
tube here it automatically turns on and
then they're every single tree has an
emitter in the soil they're called spot
spitters and you can get those products
at uh
drip Depot is probably a good company uh
drip works I think is another one that I
recommend and they all have roughly the
same Parts same prices
and you can't go wrong uh what you want
to do is give your fig tree water
especially during the growing season
about a half gallon of water roughly
every day you can start off with a
fourth of a gallon
especially when the temperatures are
warm guys they need more more and more
water earlier in the season when it's
cooler and there's not a ton of leaves
on these trees just yet you don't have
to go crazy
but as the season goes on as it's 90
degrees out here today you got to give
these trees roughly a half gallon of
water
per five gallons of soil
now if you have a larger container
with more leaves bigger tree you may
have to expand that but start off with
roughly a fourth of a gallon
then go to a half gallon then maybe go
to a gallon and just from there you'll
have enough water to keep your tree
happy and healthy and that's roughly it
one of the most important things though
I'll mention
when it comes to Growing fig trees in
containers is the soil
because you could water your tree
actually too much especially when
they're young and that will lead to root
rot figs are very prone to root rot
and so what I like to do is actually get
myself a nice compost mix you can get
Pro mix by the way that's an easy one
just go to the store and get pro-mix
already mixed for you it's peat moss and
perlite a little bit of mycorrhizae in
there you're going to be set otherwise
get yourself some kind of compost blend
that's organic
that's a potting soil or a soil
conditioner typically you can add things
like bark vermiculite perlite rice holes
different materials like that because we
want to have somewhat of a well-draining
mix in containers we don't want to have
something real heavy we don't want to go
to our yards and just dig up our native
soil and put it in a container that can
sometimes be too heavy especially if
we're growing in a lot of clay
worm castings could be good compost that
you make can be good all these things
really help the drainage and the air in
our soil if we have good air we have
healthy soil and then healthy Roots so
that's really the key that's the main
things other than that just make sure
they're getting as much sunlight as
possible
the more the better and I would also
recommend especially early in the season
give them more warmth put them somewhere
like on your patio that has a lot of
radiating heat maybe it near your house
maybe near a structure maybe just some
way
near big boulders or something just some
way to warm up that soil and keep it
warm for as long as possible
the last thing I'll mention I for I
almost forgot about this is Mulch and so
wood chips are a great idea
to add to any Tree on top of the soil
I have wood chips virtually on every
tree
and I do this religiously in the ground
but also now in container fig trees as
well and this will just keep regulate
the soil moisture and also regulate the
soil temperature
especially in places like Arizona
West Texas
Southern California it can be very hot
we're in the South like Florida Georgia
it can be too warm believe it or not to
grow fig trees in containers so we want
to put that Mulch on top and that's
going to help really regulate that soil
and we're going to be Off to the Races
your trees are going to do great if you
guys have any questions contact me on
the blog figoss.com or put a comment
down below please check out the blog hit
that subscribe button for me hit that
like button
see you guys for the next one take care